This year you have the opportunity to go to Davos for the World Economic Forum's annual meeting
And make your idea.
My name is Rebeccea McQuigg
I'm Julia Lalla-Maharajh
Hi I'm Sloane Berrent
I was chosen to go to Davos in 2009 to attend Davos
I was in 2010 MySpace Wallstreet Official Citizen Journalist
I was elected in 2010 to attend Davos
One of the key issues of this year's agenda is how everyone can benefit from economic prosperity - including growth
Did you know that the global economy is worth over $ 70 trillion,
And yet more than 3 billion people live for less than $ 2.00 a day? How can we close this hole?
Upload and submit your video that describes an idea that you think can drive inclusive growth.
If your idea is chosen, you have the opportunity to present it in front of people who can make it a reality.